bien loin des polémiques européenne sur
le glyphosate localement habitants élus
associations et agriculteurs de la
plaine de versailles planchent sur les
enjeux agricoles de leur territoire un
territoire prisé avec douze nouvelles
exploitations qui se sont installés
récemment un record en ile-de-france
qu'il est nécessaire de préserver ce que
représente la plaine de versailles est
un système de biodiversité dans tous les
sens du terme et que pour qu'on puisse
avoir une nourriture de qualité et bien
il faut que les acteurs c'est-à-dire les
agriculteurs mais aussi les
consommateurs jouent le jeu
comment favoriser la consommation locale
comment produire de façon responsable et
satisfaire la demande des consommateurs
la soirée s'est déroulée autour de trois
tables rondes et a permis de soulever de
nombreuses problématiques autour du
modèle agricole actuel
l'objectif est en fait de réussir à
montrer que le cahier des charges en
agriculture française est vertueux sain
et assure vraiment un gage de fiabilité
et de sécurité alimentaire organisée par
deux députés de la république en marche
cette réunion publique s'inscrit dans le
cadre des états généraux de
l'alimentation lancé il ya quatre mois
partout en france
objectif rapprocher l'ensemble des
acteurs de la filière
ce qui m'a vraiment motivé aujourd'hui
c'est de voir
ce renouveau dans l'agriculture ces
jeunes agriculteurs qui s'investissent
ce qui m'a plu aussi c'est de voir qu'il
y avait juste des consommateurs qui sont
venus aujourd'hui qui sont en demande
qui sont en attente d'une solution sur
des circuits courts qui ont besoin
d'informations sans calendrier fixe pour
le moment les états généraux de
l'alimentation devrait déboucher sur un
projet de loi dès le premier semestre
2010 8